well ladies and gentlemen it is the
fighter and the Vaughn cuz yeah it is
late as [ __ ] well so will you strike it
up bro well it's ironic that the kid
behaves like one right let's rock that
cannon goes bro super late lost track of
time and that and I just responded back
your 50 yeah you're 50 years old that's
what this is this Brian the kid lost
track of time
my favorite is he's gonna come back I
thought we said one yeah no say dude
there's a pipe that busted off the 405
I'm like well no I took about five here
yeah look I'm some crazy advocate in
here Yeah right so we got him cornered
yeah we I'm true yeah fire dude this guy
I've never been met around anybody who
been around this many fires every ever
been another other place with him oh the
huge fire huge fire on La Cienega sure
guy he told me one he goes dude a water
main broke off Pacific why the [ __ ]
anywhere there I live off Pacific yeah
there's no water main I got you know
life wage I go really
no that's anything out the [ __ ] way
enough water everywhere bro well he also
has a scanner he's and here's the thing
you people that are laid and constant
and laid and you know just selfish with
other people's times that's what it is
it's helped us with other people's time
don't you doubt on that brother yeah how
its up but I saw you last night he'll
just at the Comedy Store it was good to
Gerard Butler was there how did you like
we're like oh [ __ ] no is sparta music
already cool bro I was just trying to I
wanted to do well for Gerard Butler how
did you know he was there though because
all of a sudden like they were like
everybody you know how there's those
seats in the back there's four five seat
yeah and they're like we need everybody
out of the seats right and I think I was
in one of the seats and so I'm thinking
somebody bigs coming in to sit in or
they wouldn't move you know that I can
move a comedian he'll know and so then
like some people came in but it's dark
in there and I'm like looking animal
you know Geena Davis may be you know a
random one my big Geena Davis fans okay
she's not as good-looking in person as
she is in league of their own
but um but anyhow they came in and then
I'm like who is that and then it's Jo
our Butler did you hear his accent now
did you know his droid Butler cuz you
saw his 300 body like those he is he
still bodied up mmm he look like about
it maybe a forty one pant
wow that is that's not Spartan life he
might be Spartan like a Greek olive or a
Greek he's more is more bulking yeah
like he's like he lives in the ball did
you talk to him um I didn't talk to him
but I heard afterwards that he said that
he asked people about my name and I did
really good yeah you're a [ __ ] killer
I did do well is that man hell yeah
and um and I wanted to meet Gerard
Butler you know how I look at him but I
didn't get that opportunity I thought
about tweeting at him today but I don't
know if that's cheesy or not what do you
think about that kind of stuff I was
gonna tweet saw Gerard bought the last
night at the Comedy Store
yo bro put me in 301 that's what I was
gonna say they've already made that they
did yeah put me in Brannon and two dog
he has nothing do with him he doesn't
when he died in the first right put me
in 299 the prequel yeah there you go
that'll work I don't know if I tweet him
that dog yeah I bet he's gonna come back
my boy went to to dinner with them and
he was saying how this might be no I
think one of my friends said he was not
smart I wasn't even going there I don't
think he's gonna solve you know [ __ ]
the AIDS crisis but I got a cousin I
don't much Abbey's one time on a picnic
and yelled at similar know what I'm
saying is that they uh that this man god
I don't think he somebody said he wasn't
super bright you know he wasn't bring it
strong he's a [ __ ] far cry from Elon
Musk
but he's not you know so he ain't making
a battleships oh hell no he's not making
battleships or taking out the Persians
but he my friend who had the
conversation with him he's like you know
most girls they think I'm rod Butler
from 300 so I got a hookup when I take
my shirt off like what like I got that's
a movie like I'm not [ __ ] a spark for
god sakes you say it's exhausting he's
like I'm sure our Butler from northern
Michigan George Butler the brake ler
dude likes to [ __ ] eat Pete's and
hang out those were the movies [ __ ]
yeah I guess it's exhausting form which
it would be well do you feel that don't
like as a fighter do you feel like if to
show up with that fighter physique and
in places because that seemed like
something I mean now I'm gonna different
Lane I feel like I'm more self-conscious
or more aware of my body now that was in
the fire to the fighter it's like but
that's fine dude I know I did oh you ass
pull the Jay car wouldn't start sucking
some dudes do this
[Laughter]
and no offense of anybody's game and I
might be gay when I'm by about 70 or 80
you just gonna switch it up well here's
what I think I feel like I came here I
came nervous to do everything that I
wanted that thing that can be done if I
can you know in due time you know riding
sharks you know decode nations and maybe
even being gay you know might be in your
future you never know I like family and
kids yeah I feel I feel like it's an
easier life like got me society but any
real society in general doesn't accept
you like they accept normal
relationships yeah you look okay in a
convertible yeah you know you wear
Gucci's with fur out the back tight-ass
pants you can't get tight enough short
shorts and the but also if I work in a
gay bar we're [ __ ] out of ten times
I'm sucking dick or getting a dick in my
ass if I go no guy
well we'll see I'm just brainstorming I
don't we're in the trust tree right now
you're right yeah yeah trust tree gay
trust tree so when I but if I go into a
straight bar chances me hook down with a
girl yeah not great yeah maybe 10
percent if you're a dime piece maybe
fifty percent fifty percent for your
diamond but if I'm gay it's one I'm
batting a thousand yeah that's true I
can't imagine so back to AIDS man I
don't think we can beat it
AIDS yeah because magic begs the differ
really yeah but Johnson doesn't have it
but dude he said I think he's drinking
you as your pubes blood because I'm
saying you gotta find that fury dude
that'll beat anything I heard two five I
heard just two drops under your tongue
Oh cure cold you know I I think he has
so much goddamn money you didn't matter
what he yeah he could get anything did
he get attacked by vultures and you'd be
able to find his way out of it when you
got that kind of money but got that
Baltimore cash that Baltimore Sun he
they say he not just him but now like
the medication for it's all good oh yeah
yeah it's not that big of a deal don't
even ride you don't want aids but it's
not like it used to be where people are
dropping like flies right if easy was a
life today got AIDS you're straight damn
that's crazy right yeah I guess it's a
shame man I don't know some of his music
wasn't that good towards the end I
thought but yeah overall I feel like
it's a shame that people that we have
diseases that we can't be it's strange
but predominately in homosexual
relationships like that but sex so it
gives you the bay yeah that's what they
get it from do you say and needles so
drug addicts or you know when you think
about it's pretty easy to avoid in then
if you're a straight man with AIDS yeah
what you doing yeah it makes you wonder
it seemed like you really wandered off
for the your line of people yeah like
you know the rumor is Charlie Sheen got
it from doing science ex-gay activity
but then all they're like most people
heterosexual don't really shouldn't
begin Hayes let's take a blood
transfusion or you're a drug addict with
needles or if your party on one item
spraying blood on each other you know
you're like oh well I guess so it's
blade for so sure
oh you got enough money do you order a
couple uh you know Hardy wristed you
know people and a couple of swords dude
who the [ __ ] knows what can happen it's
just so Richard King created vampire
Dyke dude I knew a guy he used to pay
Vietnamese dudes come beat his ass dude
for like a thousand bucks
yeah wait guys and just be as those in
the Hollywood Hills dude this dude would
pay these two Vietnamese dudes drive up
there 500 each and beat the [ __ ] out of
them dude he's like you just got off on
it yeah just got beat up and then I
guess he'd just lay there or something I
go to bed I don't know I think he was
here's what I think I think he was doing
bad business dirty business and he felt
bad about it but he didn't feel like he
was able to stop doing the business
because the money was making so he
needed some sort of repercussion some
sort of like like yeah so so he would do
it basically like I well I'm gonna do
this but yeah go and whoop that ass yeah
I need to get doesn't make it right
right doesn't make it right but at least
I'm like I'm I'm getting my own prize
yes at least there's some repercussions
for my actions I'm paying a price so at
least then you could like you know send
a mass text to people you're [ __ ]
over you just lay in there bleed some of
your money I made off of you have you
had any kinky [ __ ] like that ever in
your friends parties anything I feel
like you live a crazy life man no did I
grew up really in the you know there
were a lot of diseases I did a I did a I
did a fundraiser last night I was at a
fundraiser from lymphoma right and I've
never even heard of it comedy fundraiser
yellow foam in leukemia you know and I
never even heard of lymphoma you know in
no offense if anybody has lymphoma but I
had um I grew up around rabies was like
the hottest thing he did you know maybe
think good a rabies get bit by a
squirrel or some [ __ ] where you're from
yeah [ __ ] that's from yeah there's a lot
of animal Stewart or cousin anybody
that's uh you know not taking good care
of themselves and they spend a lot of
time outdoors and you can to dead
giveaways that people have rabies are if
they're afraid to drink water and if
they're kind of playing hide-and-go-seek
by themselves
a bit like if you see them yeah except
them and that's that's rabies - rabies
yeah like you don't know beat it
don't you die yeah and you can look that
up dude I don't know what actually you
can Bobby just close your eyes and know
you know and now they work that's the
dark arts boy hey wait I feel like
rabies is a problem Oh in the South
though I liked up to say now in the
South I think NASCAR rabies by rednecks
you know own a Tony Stewart poster
[ __ ] Jeff Gordon - head - yeah I
think so Danica Patrick brazier on fried
food NASCAR rabies is the South man that
I tour in the south so I brake killing
my ticket sales but you know I'm saying
like rabies in LA is not a big issue no
it's not a big issue I think people
don't spend enough time with real ass
animals all these animals out here
[ __ ] trained imports fake guys
little Dalmatians and [ __ ] it's some gay
man to live out a park by me used to put
spots on his own [ __ ] get it together
brother
[Laughter]
what happened why would the guy put I
don't know I don't know that man I'm
gonna go by people like that if some new
spot in his own petrol I'm out no it's
not like Dalmatians are rare some [ __ ] I
get if you have a pet right I wanna
paint them white and then one
but with [ __ ] Dalmatians Paton talks
is insane yeah that's people in parks
man people do anything in a park out
here you got a notice that out here like
where I'm from a park is a place to
picnic you know
Micheline yeah chill out make art or
something but frisbee yeah I hear it's a
lot of drug scene drug people living out
there yeah well gang activity lot but
sex yeah Magic Johnson that's what they
call it you know people out there
getting that Magic Johnson is one of his
favorite players then even gettin a it's
from a dude is crying with another dude
gift you know Noble he's supposed to
write a letter to him the veil that hope
he gets better [ __ ] [ __ ] up my
afternoon weird my aunt nobody's car and
we out baseball a pack of cards and he
pulled up Magic Johnson start crying
right then we know he's wins dude that's
how he sound pretty emotionally a week I
can see how you were the fighter he'd
that do it he would tap out if he caught
a tough cold no no no way tougher than
foam really yeah he'll take that magda
Johnson AIDS anger out honey I'm gonna
[ __ ] is nasty that's cool mmm-hmm that's
cool he's the guy you don't want to [ __ ]
with but yeah man happy to be here dude
and I'm me to me I'm impressed you keep
going on with the comedy man I know it's
not you know my opinion doesn't matter
and I guess it's not really a judge
we're picking does matter but it's cool
to see dude it's just cool to see that
you know you continue to you know to do
it and just you know try it even if
you're just trying it it's so cool that
you continue to try yeah grind it man
yeah cool that story yeah yeah it's neat
man so it's a that's brave dude
cuz that's a total different universe
how does watch some of those fights the
other night Michael by sting and who's
the other man genno st. Pierre
what did you think that stuff man do you
watch a lot of oh no no there's only
second fight ever watch are you oh was
the first flight you watched first fight
over watch was Nicholas Diaz against
that's not Floyd Mayweather who is it
who do you fight
Oh Conor McGregor Nicholas Diaz I'm sure
he loves you call Nicholas then is his
full name though yeah I met his brother
one time Nate yeah Nathan did I met
Nathan Diaz and he he was wild he had a
chip on his shoulder man yeah that's
them man that guy but he was also a
really really neat dude great guys but
yeah chips on the shoulder great guys
but yeah you don't want to yeah walk by
him in the dark I thought I was here to
be in a conversation you know a little
bit but also at the same time was love
in the conversation that I was in man
really um yeah I was just doing Opie and
Jim Norton back when they had a show
together and how long ago was that this
is probably a year and a year ago
because they probably quit or maybe a
buddy maybe about 68 18 months you've
been doing comedy for how long maybe 13
years maybe 13 that's a long last time
yeah it's like a time warp it doesn't
nothing changes
Kalen doesn't get any older as if he
does so if he does yeah just keep saying
he's not older then one day is just not
gonna show it died from old age we're on
here just hating on him he'll die in a
fire finally Oh Dino finally something
happens finally a water main breaks and
he dies in it that's how we find out he
wasn't lying
I've got the femurs of new material
no all right but he's like Bobby Lehman
I can watch it if I can watch his show
and even though it'll evolve it's just
it's still funny every time yeah yeah
they have a unique gift of the dynamic
yeah you can just look at them and
they're funny you know it's a nice but
yeah there's some element there where
their punch line has already set up he's
a lot of community have to write the
punch line buh-buh-buh-buh-buh yeah but
more performance comedian yeah we're
we're I think that like I always say
this about Kalin I think he's better in
person than he is if you listen to him
on audible or on visually yeah video
in person is where you get the fool you
get that fire yeah if he shows up if he
shows that I took and he shows up he's
half an hour late now that's whatever
yeah and Counting dude and we got you
made a beautiful cookies this morning MJ
made us cookies finally yeah I'm talking
all the [ __ ] yeah there's a little
harassment in the workplace here gay or
no since it's that time of year
Kalyn jacked off in a pot next door and
I held her down like Kevin Spacey so
very softly yeah yeah but she got out
she has good Jitsu she's pretty flexible
why you dude you just you oh I do yoga
yoga so you know she does I might be des
doesn't in Santa Monica Saint carita
where's that at oh yeah
Six Flags I've been up there one time I
love yoga dude I just started getting
into it do oh dude I feel I [ __ ] do
workout in general I used to
I should be in like powerlifting and
everything dude I used to be jacked back
in the day
really I was an animal dude I was
[ __ ] we're on them protein powder
under my steroids the whole steroids for
a while when I was young really yeah you
aren't serious dosterone
something yeah you started to run a
stack just to get jack yeah I was like a
southern stack it was like testosterone
and like Crisco or something contesting
gravy daddy ball and [ __ ] so yeah at
one point I couldn't I use q-tips in my
ears cuz I couldn't get my really yeah
is there pictures online of this I don't
know there might be there [ __ ] find
that chin it might be I'm just doing it
just for just to try it out or what I
mean if you want to really know when I
really think back and what I was doing
yeah I'd love that I was just how old we
first of all yeah I was let me see 17 or
18 nope it was after that that's when I
got involved in this damn cult [ __ ] a
real cult are you not on set there
that's out and Reseda dude what are you
doing huh why are you looking for the
Lord brother what do you think I was
doing same thing you probably were
but uh hey man what do you get a bro
whatever dude
you never hung around black people
things happen breath well it looks like
you're in like Africa there yeah well
that Robbie I used to santa clarita and
you were just trying to blend in just an
adult yeah dude it's uh rural it gets
pretty long enough to kiss the sweats
you know long enough to put a warp zone
in your spirit I was out there dude
eatin [ __ ] dolphin dandruff doing dope
out there boy playing Color Me Mine with
my own body living out there boy making
pottery out of my dick but I'll tell you
this man what are we talkin about
Oh steroids what steroids pork you
wearing a cult yeah man I'm doing that's
the dark arts brought in and I've been
in the dark on some dark places there
bro but I never been in a fire on La
Cienega lasted this one [ __ ] but yeah
I used to use them in enhancing drugs
and I'll used and the only thing I was
really getting performance enhanced for
was really the 11th grade Wow laughing
so hard
feels been killing it you made me laugh
yeah dude good to see you bro that's
great to hear
thank you guys for having me no I won't
be it's good time you look like you've
been crying
dude he's being shitty I posted I swear
guys it clean I think yeah I don't like
now yoga and outdoor
um but teal but Theo did steroids back
to the white and the steroids I was
young you performance-enhancing drugs
you you used him haven't you no really I
want to don't somebody that's definitely
googled HGH on the wind yeah I kind of
grandma afraid of HGH but I'd like to do
I'd like to do testosterone I think
that's what I did we bought some shitty
Mexico and snuck it back in a shampoo
bottle and still used it really you're
straight we're using dirty stuff and I
was straight yeah I've always been
straight well I know some just feels
good on it you know what here's what it
was man I just was in fear I just felt
inferior growing up and I just here's
what happened I'm man yeah I met a gay
man because we both bus tables that um
could have been Italian food I remember
what kind of food it was vague Bistro is
vague Bistro all right and it was it was
it was and uh and then what happened was
he ended up having drugs he was Italian
you look like don flamenco from Mike
Tyson's punch-out you bring our pitcher
Don flamenco rosin his mouth was that
the rose in the mouth yeah that guy that
guy oh yeah bring him up the first guy
right there yeah let's go with the rosin
with one of the right one more oh he
looked just like him right okay and he
was homosexual and he was a busboy as
well even though he's an adult and he
got me into doing steroids and we still
run marijuana back and forth across the
causeway bridge right pounds of
marijuana and he actually did a bunch of
pills later and died driven to an
embankment but one night I'm over at his
house I know one item over his house
Princess Diana died I knew Princess
Diana was dead really I thought Princess
Diana was like the mayor of our town or
something like I didn't really know what
was going on okay you know yeah
we're sitting over his house Hiles of
marijuana and he started crying in
Sampras's Diana died and he had just
made us some chicken me and him and corn
and we're sitting there just having a
meal I don't know who Prince Donna was I
was high as [ __ ] and then he said he had
steroids and then next one months we
used to go I think he loved me honestly
you guys ever we never made out or
anything I was 16 he ever make like
Kevin Spacey move on you're nothing like
no see
hold you down till he does always took
care of me do you think it was that kind
of like almost like a thing as he was
probably bout thirty it was thirty year
old boys you were how old at the time
that's why he he loved man but he in a
weird way too though yeah but just like
in it but he was also the toughest dude
in the red try to get like dude is but
in a weird way he would knock anybody in
around he might even knock this girl out
oh he's tough guy I mean he was just a
tough like tough softer dick but you
know who dude he'll suck your dick and
then knock you the [ __ ] out did you ever
see him like [ __ ] dudes or anything
since he was a dick suck nah yeah I
think he might know he would just accuse
everybody of being gay all the time
which I was doing anyway - yes fun yeah
I was like at that age where he's like
man seems you don't know he live with my
brother though I said to my brother
they're both in your roommate and they
were good friends he was a good friend
to him a took care of me just he was
just like a buddy like I never had like
kind of like a older brother kind of
father for this like kind of that figure
he was open about his game sad that he
died yeah he was open about it okay and
he was cool and then he and we were both
Busboys you know he he couldn't get
gainful employment because he had he'd
been in jail in and out of jail a felony
yeah and I couldn't get gainful
employment I was 15 you know so it's
kind of like that you know we met the
lobby on space he has the odd couple
yeah but then we started doing drawing
testosterone and we pull over 30 years
old doing testosterone and pull over on
the side of the interstate and shooter
in each other's butt cheeks damn you
never tried nothing sorry they never
even touch my butt weird or anything man
Wow really he would inject you with the
testosterone
yeah I mean I was afraid to do it yeah
once a week I don't remember what it was
you know we just did a cycle of it it
was probably he was probably grooming
you he's like soon as the kid turns 18
oh no I think yeah I mean I'm one for me
you know yeah you'll cheat if somebody
under age [ __ ] yeah
I mean no but I don't think he was
trying I don't think he was doing that I
never felt that it's the sounds trying
to take care [ __ ] that that sounded that
common you know
steroids secret yeah and he just uh yeah
he was a good dude man he was he was
probably like the first yeah he's just
like a good friend man I know it sounds
crazy like you know but I think he died
I think he dated uh you know I think I
might have he told me about dates he
went on and [ __ ]
you know so I don't think he was trying
I'm talking girls and [ __ ] yeah yeah
yeah was dating girls yeah he would come
he would like he we throw away my
brother would throw parties because both
of them were partying and stuff so they
would throw parties and I'd have big
parties over there why do you think you
have low self-esteem because like like
he'll crush a room and then I was
watching the other night laughing my ass
off and you followed me
and he gets off and goes I didn't really
get him I was like what the [ __ ] are you
talking about yeah you did yeah you
always say that because you feel yeah I
don't know artists don't feel unless
it's like I don't know I just don't feel
like sometimes you notice one feel that
great I guess it's probably the only
thing like I think like when you don't
feel that great about yourself we were
talking about this one time recently
that's kind of good for a comic like
hell yeah you should done real something
no you should I want you to go into that
though well cuz I figured there'd be
something oh yeah I mean I just um you
know I don't know I think growing up ah
this was super him you know I just felt
you know I just didn't feel that good
you know I just didn't feel that you
know I didn't feel sure myself I don't
feel that good I think probably no I was
young I didn't have like you know people
telling me that everything was okay you
know and if you don't have that voice
ingrained in you then you just always
kind of like hear on a little bit of
like a you know a teeter totter and you
just feel a bit nervous you know
stability
yeah there's no stability kind of inside
me so I think that's why I tried things
like doing steroids or you know getting
in a you know drugs and alcohol or
probably even maybe comedy you know just
searching out for something to make me
feel you know just searching out for
stuff
does comedy fill that void and all or no
what comedy makes it so it made us
always in control of everything
so if I'm on the stage I have the
microphone I can control everything goes
so if I can control how everything goes
then I can't leave it up to anybody else
to make me feel bad you know that's
interesting it limits the percentage
chances of anybody making me feel bad so
then if I get really good at what I'm
doing and if I know everybody's laughing
and they couldn't not like me you know
like they couldn't you can't laugh and
[ __ ] hate somebody at the same time
as hard and maybe that's why I do it to
get to be a wizard really to do that
just figure that out that's interesting
so I think if I can make people laughed
and I'll be like ok I don't have to
worry for a second everybody I'm ok no
everybody feels like I'm ok
and there's ever a time when you're
content you're always just yeah when I
kill it usually then I know it right
after yeah when I feel pretty good but
now it's getting better man I mean I go
to like now I'm gonna dolt I go to
therapy and do all that kind of stuff to
try and you know battle that inner [ __ ]
so I don't you know we go to therapy huh
I mean therapy one time a week just once
yeah for an hour yep one hour this lady
Joanie do they figure anything out is it
more you just talk into them
no this lady's pretty good man you know
I go for like adult sex therapy or
something you know and they talk about
sex and they talk about you know like
you're an addict no dude I like I don't
even really care about sex that much
like I think sex kind of born like
you're banging each other for [ __ ]
eight minutes and then you know
everybody just kind of lay it sitting
around the room it's kind of like a
[ __ ] bad fight after you're done they
come over maybe because you're a
handsome dude and popular dude say you
know ladies yeah but like you could go
the John Muir route where he said so
much sex he's like [ __ ] it and start
doing dudes
really that's what about John Mayer it
is now dude it is now is it have you
added a view is that are you saying that
you've had orgies and you've been and I
mean up in it I was involved with a
couple of girls that were cousins one
time in Indiana actually and then you
kind of learn I think every cousins they
are now dude I'll say that brother at
least you're definitely tied together
that's kind of like a that's kinda like
it's like you just got you just fought
every time a breath and just tired like
alright what now I guess bar clothes
back on and maybe drink some [ __ ] ice
tea would you talk that there's
therapist about sex but if you don't
care about it with that part of it it's
like you gotta care about stuff so it
just makes you wonder like I just like
to start thinking about why feel certain
or just start like trying to figure out
what I feel you know trying to figure
out do they always feel like and I
haven't seen a therapist talk about this
but is don't they just chalk it up to
your childhood
yeah a lot of times every time you
a lot well a lot of times but then you
just tell the stories like answers
challenge egg thank you I'll see you
next week cool our again it's cuz your
shitty father they can get in your head
like like but yeah it's true sometimes
they can man I mean this one kinda helps
me think about stuff sometimes I
overthink things but I don't know I like
to try and get involved in why I'm
feeling a certain way as you know it's
good to navigate it yeah and talk it out
to have someone who's not but you know
biased or yeah watch sometimes they can
be biased oh and they can't help it like
I went to a couples therapist that's
different yeah because the guy said to
me to pee trying to figure me out and he
goes he goes so what do you how'd you
well I went to boarding school when I
was 14 and he goes all your parents
threw you away Wow and I was like legit
boy hey man I don't don't say it like
that camera sound ooh wow I could see
you in a recycling band oh that's crazy
your parents threw you away no a
floating down the river somebody finds a
recycling bin in here in there
you're just [ __ ] lifting weights down
in their training banana you have any
problems with depression or anything
yeah most I had a lot of problem with
that growing up but now I don't have
them as much anymore you know does the
medication or BN is on medication I take
low-dose medication and then you know
I'm just more like I think confident now
these days you know just getting and
also figuring that [ __ ] out you know
like I'm a big proponent if I feel a
certain way I want to try and figure out
why do I feel that way you know so it's
kind of fun it's a journey you know it's
just like train and it's like you know
you have to go you know I like you know
you have to start to figure it out you
know and the more you do it the easier
it gets you know but anyway do you find
any success in it though yeah really I
am yeah I'm finding awesome so what
makes me want to do it yeah like yeah
yeah just like yeah man I wish I could
give like a you know real concrete
example but does it make you more aware
like why you feel so yeah like one more
aware of triggers and things yeah a
hundred percent and it makes it so that
you know like the other day like I was
hanging out this girl I could tell she
wanted me to say like this she was
pretty right like not another way she
was asking for
for some sort of like God you know like
looking to feel good she just was kind
of feeling unsure about herself and all
I had to say was like you know I think
you're you know pretty just something
she was looking for something light like
some sort of yeah confirmation right and
just in as a human being I should have
said it's what a nice person was yes a
hundred percent and I'm a nice guy could
it you know but something in Sodom is
like man if you say that then it's like
part of you're given some a weakness
there's some weakness there I was afraid
to say it I could feel like I was afraid
Wow not like how I didn't want to to
make her feel bad but just like man if I
say this
then the shows get over you or something
or she's gonna know that I care you know
or that I'm sort of care and then if I
care then she's got that over you yeah
and that means I'm a caring person and
so all these things that maybe are built
in the back of my head where I'll just
care about myself
now I start to care about other people
what's how is that gonna feel inside of
me Wow
so just weird [ __ ] like that they start
to kind of figure it out anyway just
kind of born what do you think why do
you want to see a therapist yeah I just
like to talk to you got good hair you'll
be fine for a while bro you got good
hair yeah decent hair bro but is listen
yeah great here you have a mullet dude I
just got some of my hair taken out of
the back put in the front bro [ __ ]
conversation the common story he comes
and goes bro
I had some hair team from the back put
in the front like why would you do that
yeah you call it in the front yeah
mullet on a Friday transplant you did it
didn't work out but you need it be you
don't know what white never know because
I guess all my mullet in the front bro
who has that way bro your hair right so
wait recede your bro bro so you actually
had a hair transplant with that hairline
yeah you're out of your [ __ ] that's
crazy all right yeah dude I'm gonna be
[ __ ] parties I get it I can be a Ewok
come come Christmas oh I did it yeah in
your eyes what did the doctors say when
you said I wanna do it he said let's do
it dude
hey they want the money and I love
surgery dude I love surgeries have you
had I've had had a bunch of quarters
taken off a swaddle much quarters and I
was a child
oh look a lot like I almost upwards
eight dollars that's right I haven't
taken out of my body
what else have I had dude I've had I've
had some other [ __ ] dude let me think
about it
oh it's high on cocaine one time with
some girl tried to cut something out of
my hip right here mmm
she like surgeries huh did they if I get
5 other people to get it in the next
year
mine's free coupons what did you do I
love those why don't you try so two of
my favorite [ __ ] things what you girl
try to cut out of your hip you can't
just like say that just like a lump
under my skin I don't know what it was
behind a fat doing whatever yeah chunk
of fat she told me she's like I can do
this right he's had a razor blade oh my
god she can't do it was she hot she's
real chatty hot goes away before the
blow oh she's loud before the blow
[Laughter]
that's what I dude I'm fearless
I'll [ __ ] do whatever dude I'll fight
I'll fight a [ __ ] unifying kid who
can [ __ ] jump I are you gonna find my
dad's to do it blind kid you could jump
I yes really high not if he trained him
kungfu cuz they teach you how to fight
like when you're blind but that's he's
probably gonna have that he's aren't
just gonna be jumping high he's not just
some buddy just standing these are
jumping high yeah if he's got frog legs
and he's just flying [ __ ] cause
I'll time it so as soon as he lands I'll
punch him in the face
I would tickle him and then just get him
to quit I don't know we'd have guys
sometimes you light up the guy and the
guy would be jumping as high as he could
you bet this guys jumping super high
like getting ready and you were just
time he'd go he jumping and you slice
that cake as he landed and kick him out
of the [ __ ] right dumbest [ __ ]
technique in the world like what are you
doing
boom boom do you think you'll be able to
find five dudes and have that here
transplant I don't think so dude I've
already had two men reach out to me
trying to recruit us you thought oh
great me I don't know you do something
yeah excuse me I'm taking propecia my
hair is movies is not population you
know it's - I don't have good hair
though it doesn't work for me they are
transplant what about getting some of
his hair I'd love it but he won't give
it out I wanted to get a wig I'm not
getting a [ __ ] wig bro dude there's a
look great wigs out there now there are
you know if I didn't know you you're
here kind of excited
is it really now it does Shh it's a
first of all you frosted right
don't [ __ ] frost you don't know dude
it's natural
really yeah look at it all do you don't
dye it uh all right so always sometimes
I'll doubt the sideburns here yeah it's
great it's all right
I'm 37 I'm adult man I don't mind it a
little bit but I don't want to be
considered like a senior or anything
before I'm supposed to be well I'm great
and I I don't I should start dyeing my
[ __ ] you dye your hair nobody no that's
that great no but your beard did I die
yeah I'm or dye your skin because it's
in contrast to your skin and I am truly
Scott hellish it's Palace green pink
it's a shitty guy I had all your from a
foggy land yeah well I'm a half time I
haven't had a girl coming to me last
night at the Comedy Store and she works
in the office and she goes I'm no I'm
not because I'm not saying this because
I think you need it
I heard you talk about the bags in your
eyes there's a procedure that we do with
ops I work at where we inject these
things into the bad guys and they don't
have bags under your eyes I kinda have
some bags absolutely not Mariah Carey
right now never notice that one time
like Trump Trump bag no.8 two ball sacks
a nobody but once you set those again
that first oh I'm good
[ __ ] you no no I don't see that then I
went home and looked at I'm like oh hell
no really
[ __ ] no needles in your eyes man oh dude
you got to go get this hair surgery then
it's awesome bro they let you watch
whatever you want the whole time you're
in there you can be on your phone come
on yeah I did beautiful babies i watch
did they literally cut like cuz you know
Rogen tried it didn't work so is that
like like he's from [ __ ] you from afar
yeah me too you have a slow yeah I got a
smiley face so what they do is they take
the signal fishes in I know how long ago
this was this was probably in I guess
about 10 years ago May
hey more cheese I don't know you said no
they get a car better your father's
believed asleep indeed this one 15 13
years ago that's our early bro they cut
out a PC or they cut out a piece of your
skin
okay they take a piece of your skin out
and linger then they sew that [ __ ] back
together now
you need to know something about me
about me got a tight skull got a tight
skull a lot of guys don't I got tight
skull like watch this when you do this
seam yeah it should move more not me
my skin my head my head skin is tight on
my uh my skin good skull though Raycom I
could see you like mesothelioma what's
that called where you have like the
early back in the prehistoric I think
mesothelioma yeah it's kind of a big
life we'll see if they would find you in
a cave hotter percent like it the best
skulls in here like I'm finding you in a
village no no no like if we all died and
you have to rank the skulls you know one
through five up in there one in MJB to
what do you mean like I'm involved
junior dead last
I'm less evolved know that you have a
nice round skull yeah like you could be
in a Halloween shops Jen's a spice
trader his to be like oh this guy came
to sell spices to him yours would be you
would be still I think in the jungle
yeah okay me as much of cracks in it
yeah dude I would probably be like in a
camp like in a prison and different
skulls I think so I am small I think I
have a small school I don't know I have
a long head you don't have a fun skull
they want to use your skull for games
and stuff after they ordered roar like a
dream yes yeah it's so cool the Vikings
will kill me they would cut my head on
my head in half yeah and then they would
drink yams for soup oh you killer talk
but your man your soup yeah your skull
would be great to sip out yeah yeah
creepy we'll just clean your skull out
not just a few tied your shoe ball is
perfect a cue no a drink on the road
yeah to go there take the surgery Herbie
oh man so so here's the [ __ ] weird
thing first while you're under
anesthesia no they just they just numb
your skull okay
it's very primitive so then they take
they take each individual hair follicle
out of the back your head where you
don't lose your hair right and then they
take it and they they dig where they
things thread it right dig holes in your
[ __ ] head they stick out your head
with holes right like arming so I had 11
highest rounds at 1100 grafts for two
years
yep it's like farming yeah it's just
like 1100 for station dude is what the
word you're looking for okay and then
they put those follicles individually in
the hole and hoping they grow you hope
they take your sake I didn't take so
well and also when they cut back here
there's a chance that they can hit a
certain nerve that will cause blindness
nope paralyze you
nope let me guess Oh on your face
frequency oh it's really [ __ ] weird
what oh wait I know don't worry keep
guessing you don't give up you just it
can cause Jesus Christ you only have to
guess it's related to it on one it's
related to it oh I know what it is uh uh
Eddie Money has it it's when your leg
doesn't work no he did when your eye
shuts off yeah you're all good your
hearing hold on when you unvoluntary
give the pupil sighs here's a handle
base and think of your stomach
[ __ ] navigating a plane you have to
work at the airport nope this is so
weird I can't believe death know were
you know it does it take then your teeth
get crooked no oh I know what it is when
your nose runs oh no I got it I got it
when you wait does it take your teeth go
crooked and yellow when you can hear a
dog whistle you get you're gonna baby no
you get a uh you get the I know what it
is not the hair it's her her pair you
get the hiccups
[ __ ] you you start having hit that so
that's it I know
Cheers hello for [ __ ] ups we're alive
well they that you can get there is a
chance you're an airport you dude if you
get hiccups there's a chance when you
get a trach this whistle
because I had Cubs but they won't go
away and they have to come and like do
something I'd rather have my here and
yeah it's your life it's a patch on the
back yeah you can hit a nerve apparently
or something yeah here we find a YouTube
video do you mind linkage in it for
somebody who's a hiccup at it my dad at
it for two weeks couldn't sleep my dad
too
he's like you only see my dad two for
two weeks I'd like to go insane you'd go
see a doctor dude you guys have to have
you on to talk about that did you guys
have an operation no they gave him
something to relax
Oh expert addict yes sir my dad - and
then he was crazy do not get a hair
transplant well too late yeah broken has
an earthworm on the back of his neck
yeah a real one
me too from the surgery oh I thought he
minute if I get a centipede on the back
of a skull like pulp fiction Wow
his head's been through battle oh he's
got that
yeah he's the dome on him yeah he
doesn't even care he's this out there
see some hair trance as people can get
hiccups after surgery oh yeah but it's
not permanent but it's annoying yeah I
mean you know what out of all the things
I know like when you get prescribed
medicine they're like could have
diarrhea think clades throwing up but
why there why that nerve that's so weird
that you haven't rigours hiccups yeah
it's like the guy who had the soccer
player whose foot was [ __ ] killing
him and they couldn't figure out what it
was
MRI and everything else and the dentist
said I think you have a nerve in your
[ __ ] mouth that is causing that
problem okay now when they took that
yeah when they took the tooth out and it
that was the one with the canines of the
kms canine how about this my dad's
friend my best friend dentist his wife
like notices a terrible smell coming
from his mouth when he's sleeping he's
sleeping with another man she goes Jesus
Christ so the doctor the dentist opens
pulls a tooth and there's a sack behind
his tooth oh of bacterial fluid breaks
by accident they're pulling it out wait
did he have a tooth removed in the sack
yes who is it from like oh now key or
something
Tirra can live a cheesy [ __ ] nurse
through days though the dentist the
dentist has his thing and he goes he
pulls his messes out and starts to throw
up the nurse walks in she starts to
throw up and then the [ __ ] you know
it's a disaster is not what smelt
[ __ ] it was the word you would kiss
apparently that smell that that when
when bacteria lives behind her - that
smell can beat all wet yes that's cat
bowel you know if you cut open a cat
bowel dude people can't even stay in the
room with you I heard it's bad yeah you
ever hooked those girls bad breath you
know what I have found over and I don't
find it as much anymore but there was a
period probably in the 2012-2013 time I
noticed a lot of women had this meaty
these kind of ham smell around their
mouth a little bit a meat smell
why do you mean like deli meat yeah kind
of just like a subway smell I hate
something rose also ways that brooches
in them - somebody's at a subway right
now listening to this dude it's Rob Lee
yeah have you noticed this cuz I said to
my buddy I was with a vegan girl and he
said she smell a little bit I go yeah
her breath he goes yep and it's
sometimes vegans no offense to any
vegans I know some vegan girls I think
it was the maybe she was eating a lot of
Muslims
it smelled like mush that girl might
just might like [ __ ] though it's
happening somebody got chalk it up -
yeah yeah
some people have fungus anims yeah they
just don't smell no like a dad a friend
[ __ ] it a manager you know is his breath
was so bad it would ricochet off the
window we were driving I told Brian you
gotta say so I told Brian like you have
got to say something brands like I'm not
saying [ __ ] we should I love them and I
love them too I think yeah you said he
had malaria and might be the liver yeah
oh yeah oh yeah John or he's eating [ __ ]
so liver liver disease can cause really
bad breath yeah and liver problems can
cause really bad breath and other times
it's there a couple things one it can be
a cavity but the other thing it can be
is sulfates versus sulfides like the
sulfur in your mouth takes on a
different form so it can be little I'm
talking about you got to be pH balanced
do get the pool gotta [ __ ] ya ptosis I'm
talking about
Brett it would shut the car down yeah
like you get out and feel sit yeah yeah
yeah Kissel I got a Google Voice number
and I will send blind text messages
people had a really bad breath great I
do active yeah people tell me this guy's
bad breath oh that's kind of nice
what just it's such a horrible thing to
let someone go through life with you
know it's like it's like somebody
doesn't have a leg but you don't tell
them and they're constantly just trying
to fill in like that who I should have
talked to and I couldn't bad rabbit and
then I remember one girl goes I can't
keep a man don't know I was like I know
[ __ ] breath horrible breath she smelled
like her breath always smelled like
they're hot enough I'll put up some bad
breath I did I was out a girl who had a
pierced tongue mm-hmm and she didn't
really take care of it
and her breath was like it was like a
muffler like a corroded muffler taste it
had rust so like there's like rusty she
tastes like a 76 Dodge that are iron in
her blood
you were tasting blood from her [ __ ]
tongue that's the iron no no no I'm
telling you I think it was the ball fee
because this is early 2000 1999 she had
that ball it wasn't stainless steel it
was just a rough battle yeah we're on
piercing tongues was like a big fish
yeah what the [ __ ] you don't had like a
stud in your tongue or lip I never had
anything like that man I'm trying to
cover ever thought of getting anything
exotic dude yeah he got his bellybutton
pierced at Spring Break one time and a
couple kids beat him that's all I
remember
that makes sense yeah call it what about
a nose ring nope you never had a nose
ring no Joel no you look sick with a
nose I tell you I would look I would get
slaughtered yes sir no you wouldn't bro
you're a solid I'd say eight or nine
your nose ring you attend I'm gonna
weigh your southern ten
with a nose 9 bro southern 9 yeah a la
nines different rules yeah you have to
be gay first of all as a man to be in LA
9 yeah so that's your like a nice job
like a 9 and you do 210 is you gay not
you at a shine there's nothing wrong
with that but you're still dude I'm an 8
with a nose ring you're 10 shop with the
nose ring I'm Angus why don't you get a
[ __ ] listen to me I'm being dead
serious now you could actually because
you're so big you could actually kind of
get away with a tiny tiniest tiny
diamond stud in your nose oh do that cuz
you're it's not for me I'm talking steel
just gets a little ring like like like
Lenny Kravitz like getting a [ __ ]
nose dude you would love yes I think
you've a spare key on it no no no comic
a nose ring no you can't do it imagine
if Richard Pryor had a nobody's gonna
talk times are different a nose ring
right there that terrible [ __ ] career
advice from Brendan yeah I can't believe
her in a fire without why were you late
today there's literature that looks like
somebody took one chair and just exact
please say yeah a big lazy boy you wanna
know I was late yeah Toronto yeah hey
Holl before he says this if you had a
gun to my head he said is Callan lyin
I would bet my entire bank account I
swear to god this is the truth I was
pitching an idea a TV show idea that I
have for us to the somebody used to run
it was a packaging agent at CA and who
used to run Fox comedy mmm
this is worth being late to because I
really want to get I had kids I came up
with an idea in the middle of it and I
was like you know what [ __ ] it it'll be
worth it
nothing untruth that's that I might I
think you had a meeting about yourself
yeah no and they're like actually ideal
for firing the kids yeah and so you
scheduled this meeting before our show
you're supposed to be at 11:30 at 11:00
no I told you 12 remember I sent you
attached well yeah yeah and I said
you'll be in at 11:00 yeah well the show
twelve I thought of taking a fifty got a
doll - no I was at that innovative
stewardess on the phone you're with
innovative no no I was with innovative
with my with my agents are you with
innovative this other woman me too
you're the Nevada yeah so the people I
innovate so CA came to innovate oh no
she's not with a CA she's getting a
mixed to be a packaging agent at CA this
sounds like a bad Netflix series all of
a sudden just where to got something
that a lifetime movie so I'm gonna
Alabama's week Huntsville a next week
Huntsville Alabama supposed to go there
- are you yeah and by the way you know
about some hunts work at stand-up live
yeah I'm going there - yeah and you know
why that's a great place something we
honor archery there no it's the more
it's more rocket scientists in
Huntsville Alabama and then anywhere
else oh and by the way base dude they
spin of Space Center we together when I
was a child dude I'm having a tough time
when I go down for comedy because
they've Rockets on great club and also
really great crowds apparently almost
really smart Alabama engineers become
this like really cool place because all
the all-knowing the Sparrow space
industry but also the science industry
all the sides is working on the genome
23andme headquarters down there it's
become this like like this unlike lab is
a rage yeah that's true
hey you guys hey sign this what's up
everybody another beaker full of gin
- did I ever say I just stand up for
[ __ ] a bunch of mostly Asian
mathematics tudents oddly I think it was
Columbia Steve Byrne was there Steve
goes we got set up with our agent and I
said to Steve ago Steve these are
they're all Asians and they were all
grad students in math Wow was it a
comedy venue or is it all room sure
wasn't
you sure wasn't even that it was a
locker Hall intellectual idea and I
believe its Columbia and I said to Steve
I go Steve I am now going to do 40
minutes on just Birds I go any bird fans
out here huh [ __ ] only guy laughing
Steve they weren't laughing laughing
having the crickets hey maths math
students a lot hour through a lot of
lonely women give birth to in
self-centered women and bird owners
that's a that's a weird animal man birds
suck [ __ ] got a limp Adam
[ __ ] and who are you to keep a bird
right Adam how deers had two of them
macaws do they describe the car
you leave them a call I shared a room
with a chat hold up MJ get that Mike
give that Mike
you lived with 26 birds you're the bird
girl oh go go go
I should have room of the chow not an
Asian person the doll now just to make
that clear I'm not trying to be
offensive
my old roommate she owned this thing
called like bird bungalow or something
in Santa Credo and so she'd bored bird
sell birds and sell the supplies so she
did it for all over Santa Rita caste and
all that area Shh balls deep in the
boobs so I was looking for an apartment
I saw her I don't want the Santa Rita
like housing ads and I walked into the
apartment and it was one like a couple
birds like oh okay that's that's fine we
lived in the top floor like a five-story
building I was like oh couple Birds
doesn't mind you know it sounds tropical
and also and they started coming in more
and more and it being music's your lace
venture petted it was insane like there
be birds was a North African Gray was
best friends with my daughter iceberg in
the world
Katie Katie Katie to my dog it would
talk to my dog meat sauce it was hard to
sleep at night like a rain forest
[ __ ] a bird dude I had I'd love to cause
and cause have so much personality
they're like you shouldn't have Mikasa
[ __ ] though so you you [ __ ] a girl
with a bird on chose to make love to a
woman
[ __ ] sounds very aggressive for what
I do but over sex oh yeah well I'm just
like [ __ ] cells they give a big attack
strategy and everything I don't have
that like I'm just kind of excited to be
there see what happens yeah shoulder
you're a bird that would get on my
shoulder while we'd make love man and we
probably and Rex maybe three or four
times and the bird was hanging in your
shoulder time I don't dig that cuz they
have claws man on your skin this one has
soft feet soft feet oh he's a house bird
wait a bit you clip their nails you know
I know but they're still cut their nails
in shape now I have parakeets I'm not
[ __ ] in their beak
you're [ __ ] that's [ __ ] dr. Gachet
their beak down low because he can shoot
long bird I was late today any shaven
birth
actually I was shaving burpees here cut
their wings too and they hate it
they're like ah how [ __ ] up is it to
own a bird though it's funny the most
[ __ ] up animal to own besides the
dolphin in the small turn bird this is
the becaus they usually only attach to
one person yep
so the macaw was even older than my
roommate it was like a 13 year old 100
over 100 it was a Raging [ __ ] to both
of us they call me crazy
how old is your roommate 31 yeah single
she'd know she - cool yeah single single
yeah yeah it's still single two birds
birds well my my bird Jezebel hated
women and so she'd come down off her
perch and run after you and try to bite
you through your shoe and she could bite
you through your she [ __ ] bird like
you had to be carefully Birds where
they're at that's what I always designed
to fly for god sakes if you get a
penguin a turkey do your thing man but
no time you know you can call my
penguins really you can get pet penguin
or turn almost ordered turkey Brown
College I tried you know what the
problem is looking at slap people really
penguin slap the [ __ ]
come on no I didn't get one cuz I want
to start a fight with I had all black
roommates on the football team like I
can't have this penguin slap my friends
danger Brennan have you seen the
Penguins fight when the one penguin
caught his mate
cheating on him and they got in a
full-on fight it's like it's a hilarious
video the Aussie guy who does all those
videos old a penguin requires a lot of
permits pay quirks
they'll get vicious consider getting a
dime I wouldn't mind starting off
assault maquette what about a I've seen
a turkey in person though yeah it's a
[ __ ] dinosaur there yes you attorney
Oh another world and chased me around a
car peacocks are wild - dude [ __ ] around
they had a couple brothers buy me used
to eat dove actually does real dog yeah
really that shoot him down squat they
would shoot him they would trap we call
brats of the sky you know that yeah
would you eat a rat come on bro no I've
spent a lot of time I penguins oh dude
one time we got a rental car and I got
dented up until we to hide the dent we
caught two pigeons and held them over
the dent until they [ __ ] and kind of
filled the dentin oh that's more than we
return the car damn yeah I move wasn't
too bad man but that's back when you
know birds are probably safe rental
truck Birds these days I think it's hit
or miss man I do
I mean I've never trusted a bird yeah
I've never ever trusted a [ __ ] bird
you ever see that gold like round
animals it seems like oh yeah like a
nice fuzzy warm animal when it's gonna
add some to your life a bird adds zero
happiness to your life well it is it
makes you wonder what does the bird want
for you you know like what does a bird
do they really have any interest so this
is it curiosity that's why yeah I think
keeping a bird
I can't imagine really the connection
there there's zero connect yeah there's
no bond yeah
oh no there is it's selfish keeping the
humor attached yeah yes like they're
made to fly in the gig again
unless you have a penguin you're shaving
their beak down [ __ ] today by
clipping their loss get the other room
while they're in okay say macaws I get
really attached to you though really yes
they love they [ __ ] love you they the
problem is they get too attached and by
the way they're really smart and you
can't just leave them alone they'll pick
their boo there dude check that out by a
penguin now only 25 dollars due to
popular demand all of our penguins are
currently sold out check back later
we have 25 bucks for our penguin yeah
Tony what's going on cuz they're trouble
they slap I don't think they slap bro
I'm telling you it was a legit concern
online yeah I really looked into it I
was gonna order one in Boulder Colorado
and then I looked up and people like
dude this ping was flipping out slap and
everyone I don't think that's true well
you should don't think about it just let
it be but I mean I'll take a slap for my
Penguin's wing
none of that not every day when you walk
in the door yeah should I just come on
right where the [ __ ] you been
it's like George st. Pierre dude well
the emperor penguin is about 4 feet high
aren't they can you bring that up
they're about 4 feet high the emperor
penguin they weigh about guess guess
they weigh about 25 to 30 pounds emperor
penguin yeah their biggest [ __ ] they're
getting more of like a just uh oh my god
four foot three
oh they bury a toe or foot that's the
size of a [ __ ] four year olds 51
pounds all the same size man you
basically have a small human slapping
yes
with a wet hand every time you walked in
the card wet handed yeah oh they're cute
huh yeah they look cute they are amazed
or slapping they're so weird-looking huh
well you know what they are they're just
dolphins that kind of evolved once they
got enough suck on it - yeah a little
bit look at them you tell me another
tall dolphin that's not a bird [ __ ] yeah
[ __ ] you do that's all feast on them all
day well we need more crossbreeding of
animals you know we're not gonna survive
look at that you know you think I think
so and I don't think some bestiality yes
and I know I've you know I've said this
before like yeah you make love to a farm
animal some type of livestock
yes gross yeah once but you make love to
a [ __ ] leopard you're a hero dude
exotic yeah you're a legend road legend
that blows YouTube uh yeah man makes
love to let that damn wild you bust in a
panther thanks dude you must be busting
loads and Tigers
you've earned it yeah checkmate sonship
that's a wrap well what was that what
was that vise thing with a [ __ ] donkeys
that's not vice it was a vice land they
do a thing where he goes and finds
people who [ __ ] that's the dark arts
dude one curious what animals even gonna
be up in like ah we've talked about mr.
hands before oh dude not for a night in
her I'm sorry interrupt your buddy Matt
buzz aldrin the other day you met him
from space did you ask him he's full of
[ __ ] man on the moon right uh uh one of
the first to me he was the first now he
was the first American yeah and I shook
hands with him how was it good
regular handed nice-looking guy nice
skin nice hair yeah well me everybody
about how the moon landing was faked
can't wait to hear your emails had a
dime with him dude beautiful lady really
hmm he's a he's a muscular guy I mean
he's 90 yeah yeah yeah he had a dive
piece with him you don't touch down in
the moon and not crush it yeah I would
just be later looks like you know he
looks like he looks like George see
Scott oh my god he looks like John Woo
or Woods what's that Robert Woods and he
looks like George looks like he needs
that aye sir John George he's Scott a
great actor he looks like a penguin hit
him a couple time
he looks like a stirring [ __ ] he
looks like the moon [ __ ] aged oh yeah
I don't want to do the movie sky look at
the similarity
holy [ __ ] they look alike they look like
old white dude look old white guys their
baby you know you're like exactly the
same correct what do you mean when you
get away every white guy in that's it
that's how it goes yeah you're right
dude I'm just uh I just wonder if
they'll be able to figure out that we
can live forever before all this is done
man they said the first person lives at
200 alive today no way they call it
being what is the word not a more a
mortal a mortal so you'll just keep
replacing parts of your body with new
body parts it's a monster so if let's
say you want to drain MJ's blood and put
in your body young blood
they've it proves getting out yeah
rejuvenate your your skin's and the dead
skin cells and stuff like that red blood
cells I can see that dude you know I've
drink somebody's blood man
no you can't you gotta inject it but I
can't drink it's [ __ ] you put it on
dude I'm sure you could hide some in
your ass and you take a little you know
sure yeah that's true well it'll go
things you just just pop it in and
squeeze it just to get that big like
True Blood he's obese student these
people they put the [ __ ] from a skinny
person into your ass do you know that
it's called a fecal transplant so what
they'll do is they'll take they'll shoot
they'll literally take a skinny person
[ __ ] and shoot it with a syringe
all the way up that person's ass why and
the idea is it changes the balance all
right there change the bacteria in the
body so that your your gut now processes
food differently and you lose weight
dude this kid used to poop in his yard
maybe bury it when I was growing up this
boy Mary over Fino no rafi no shots of
Mary why did Mary exhale passed away
drove and he actually drove a boat into
an embankment
damn drugs again it was drugs I think
drugs and alcohol wait so he would poo
into and say hey chill out you [ __ ] on
the yard and like y'all do come buried
in his yard make me hide it make me why
would you who's he older he was older
and was he dropping logs I don't
remember that much about the actual
poops but it was he was more he was just
older and I felt like you know to hang
out I had to cover shoot
was that a fetish of his was he like I
don't know he was not able to
communicate well about his thoughts or
feelings and sawdust remember he'd [ __ ]
I'd bury it and that was a lot of our
French that was the relationship you
didn't play like cars or video games
just play this [ __ ] game I mean I think
we did other stuff but he was like
always kind of like he was like loud as
I was aggressive I was passive you know
had a [ __ ] shovel and that was it
that was our relationship all right I
probably buried 200 that man's poop yard
wow it's a lot of poop in a jar though
so never really disintegrates it gets
not in a jar no jar why would you put
it's on the ground of [ __ ] over your
eyes to bear in his yard
see [ __ ] in his yard and you would go
and bury it yeah but he died though huh
passing away a lot of your old friends
and aquaintenances died yeah I think
people that end up doing drugs and you
know driving machinery at high speeds
don't
it's the odds or I guess it doesn't mix
at a certain point when you think about
it name anybody uses a lot of drugs and
drives at top speed who's still alive
mm-hmm I can't only know two and both of
them died but because we well I think
the odds are so many where people get
away with it we just hear about the ones
who get caught yeah yeah you ever fall
asleep the wheel oh yeah yeah I fell
asleep one time this cop wakes me up
right he goes did you did you see him do
you know where they're at I'm like what
no idea what's going on right he goes
somebody called in two wolves were
fighting in the street here dude I'm at
an intersection of this
town browser I lived in this side town
for a little water in high school I fell
asleep at the [ __ ] wheel right so I'm
dead asleep cop wakes me up right he's
like did you see it
and I almost like what I'm just thinking
was you know I did I do it was I
involved in it Who am I
and he's like talking to somebody else
to other guys probably sakra Street you
know and he's like - somebody called it
in - wolves fighting in the intersection
and I'm like thinking we don't even have
wolves in Louisiana you know so how are
you really out here looking for that but
also but also yeah me too was riding
driver who's obviously stopped anyway
card if you see anything let us know and
they were out no problem
damn joking I mean while they're on acid
because they're there see you know a cop
I used to have a prom fall asleep at the
wheel we were driving to Vegas on a road
trip and he's like don't fall asleep I'm
like I got this man and I'm driving and
I fall asleep and you know what woke me
up
wow you don't want him snoring what
Kalen no my buddy buddy that's you how
can dangerous I was driving yeah my
friend tell me if that starts to happen
take the tongue take your try this take
the tip of your tongue and tickle the
roof of your mouth and guess what it's
never worked once try it though well I'm
not tired though right now yeah my tire
right now so I'll be awake either way
take a look okay
tons of things out there don't work
touch yourself roll down the windows
loud music if I'm attractive heat on
face [ __ ] [ __ ] I pull over
dude when I was young I fell asleep at
the the premiere of Teenage Mutant Ninja
Turtles my dad made two lines in to our
lines I fell asleep there we went to a
monster truck rally I fell asleep there
oh I fell asleep at Game seven when a
Tumbo beat the Seattle Seahawks I mean
see how I fell asleep in Smashing
Pumpkins Kahn
that's a great concert yeah well I mean
it could have been me I fell asleep I
fell asleep at the wheel probably at
least 40 times I fell asleep during
driver's ed while I was driving the car
the driver the guy operate that's not
the man the adult with the license like
you're gonna fall asleep I was like no
way dude
16 seconds later [ __ ] dead asleep
right we had to pull over
there's no music right get up fall
asleep everywhere falling asleep indoors
outdoors fell asleep oh no I fall asleep
some really good place did you have
those friends when you'd fall asleep
they'd [ __ ] with you I hate that [ __ ] I
draw on your face a dick no we didn't
have any of that day all pictures dicks
in your mouth or vice versa sleeping
[ __ ] here our Vice Principal Raleigh
Coleman who was an urban gentleman and
who had a um a ie black jheri curl
okay he could have been black he was
dark jheri curl open gentleman he used
to sleep in the trunk of his car at
[ __ ] recess dude he got sneak over
about a teacher parking lot just cuz he
didn't want to assume yep and he would
tie off his trunk with a little rope so
I was about three inches high and he was
getting look at that bumper this dark
though you know idea it'd be hot yeah in
Louisiana I don't know why he liked it
but I think he just felt comfort in
there somehow you know I had no I didn't
have a parent I don't know what some of
his issues the jheri curl would explain
a little bit but curled up boy
Raleigh you don't see a lot of Jheri
curls this day and age and I asked
somebody that if they would come back
and some guy got offended at me Oh black
gentleman yeah he got offended at me
saying this you know you know dude I was
uh I took my son this place it's like a
gym and this this african-american mom
brings her son there and this kid is a
spitting image of John Legend wow he
looks like John Legend if they did a
mini Europe he looks i dented
I wanted to say that tour Mike is that
racist no if I go you does anyone told
you he looks identical John Legend here
just say it I think I know but it's just
I don't know person if John Legend were
Irish it might be crazy you know yeah
yeah I just want the kid looks identical
to John Legend wow that's pitting images
I'm scared to say it beautiful man dude
I remember I saw John Legend when Thomas
Freeport Louisiana small
yes yeah yeah is definitely middle or
medium or less I think it's like my size
he's only more less I was in a premiere
when he was MIDI was low medium and he
wonder man yeah Wow that's true and
that's a lie so it's five eight it says
Bruno Mars five five and he's five to
Buster five seven Chrissy Teigen five
nine boy you know how John Legend got
discovered Kanye West he's playing in a
hotel yeah yep Kanye West found him gave
him a start well so I was in Shreveport
Louisiana and Andy Dick offered to give
me a blow job at a strip club right and
I told him no welcome same you welcome
to club yeah
carry on say Miami takes our town so
fast forward three years later I'm back
in Shreveport Louisiana working on the
comedy club for some reason Andy Dick's
there shooting something working on
something I don't know what he hit him I
had a child down there that he was going
down to keep I don't know same strip
club back over to Andy Dick's her again
doesn't even remember three years later
we offered to blow me offers to give me
a [ __ ] again again just trying to see
irony
I've never even met him in Los Angeles
you're good dude he's so crazy but then
we all go over to a party and John
Legend was playing there it's some
little uh some little bitty party
killing it before his big beautiful
killing it yeah before he's big so Andy
Dick asked you ready do it set at the
Comedy Store
I don't know any at all mm-hmm and it's
just me and him in the back on nervous
it's like a year ago he comes sits down
next to me goes how are you doing oh my
god I'm good man and he sits like that
you out is back there's you just like
the sides of this he's just close to you
Oh bro next to me goes how you doing I
go I'm good man don't even the mic
working so many complaints
yes so he sits next to me starts doing
that I don't know him at all he goes I
fell you know I've got thirsty again I
fell off the wagon I'm like very cool I
don't know he has a problem he go oh
good luck with that man
so he was talking about how he had a
relapse and drinking stuff like that he
talked about how he's gonna go on before
me cuz all I'm gonna do is go out there
I'm gonna play the flute I'm gonna run
back and you come on like all right
whatever you want to do man you play the
flute that's gonna be a nightmare
he goes out there he's out there for
like 40 minutes just doing I like
tangling the audience
without the grand [ __ ] then I go anyways
comes back you said I'd love to be on
your show get give your number to my
system a guy that seems fair enough I
can I don't know any stories nothing
like that next day I get attacks hey
it's Andy would love to figure it out
you should stop by and let me suck your
dick right now you know how we joke
around you think it was a Miss we honest
I put I put haha
can you imagine goes yeah I can
seriously come to this is I will suck
your dick like oh he's dead serious
Wow he's always been there and he's very
straight for a while he's like I don't
care I like boys and I'm not gay I
kissed a boy you know I'd rather have
that than him I can't come in so we can
do it and then you're Harvey Weinstein
that know yeah I know buzz going it's
great and he's very upfront he's very
honest like he likes guys and girls and
he's [ __ ] he's a great guy fired from
the [ __ ] right for the sexual assault
case but man he lost his job his sexual
assault yeah which was [ __ ] up because
Andy's the kind of guy yes I lick people
yes I kissed them and they just all over
yeah he's just a sweet man who's so
funny he's such a [ __ ] hilarious man
he's just has an issue with alcohol and
he does lick you sometimes yeah all
right you know he's a wild cat he's not
creepy he's just hilarious they all in a
while harmless he's harmless and he's
wonderful you know he's like to having a
pet penguin yeah yeah he's a dick with
his mouth yeah but he's all over he's
harmless and he's not you know a lot of
these allegations man I wish that Harvey
Weinstein I hope if we know whenever he
goes down in the end I hope he also you
know names all the women that banged him
for role who are killing it right now
yes if he's like you want you I play
this game well I did this this this than
this for them and now she's here cheesy
chair
[ __ ] you [ __ ] you I'm out but also King
but also no I would just say I would
just say right he has issues but I would
also in addition to all these issues and
the things that he's done wrong I wish
he would also be like but here's five
women who came to me and said I'm gonna
[ __ ] you right now for this role yeah
and like you'd be some major names do I
bet right but just because there's some
overlap in there of a lot of this stuff
that's going on it's just tough to see
man just get all the brunt of some of
the darkness out so he stay
in some swings and he said some homeruns
as far as celebrities who came to him
and he's made their careers you know I'm
saying yeah there's a reason why he's
this way all the time
right I'd mix in there you talk to a
criminal defense lawyer about this and
he looked at the case in New York that's
against him for rape and he said the
problem is that the issue is that she
claimed you raped him I raped her which
he very well may have the only issue is
that apparently they had two more
encounters where they had sexual contact
and that was sort of like so that's
gonna throw a real wrench in not really
not really
I get that defense law but just because
they've had consensual sex before know
this rape apparently no obviously but
what I'm saying is apparently after the
alleged rape there was two more licenses
it was the guy [ __ ] was at her door
and like barged in you know in a village
yeah well I think that guys probably got
to be the biggest scumbag on the planet
yeah and he's a bad example Atul because
because you know it is true there are
too many stories from too many women
where this [ __ ] guy well your your
whole careers on the line and you get up
there and he's in a robe and he
basically is like you know and he's a
monster
come on you read this article about him
having hiring ex Israeli spies - aunt -
basically spy on all the accusers the
accusers and the journalists get dirt on
this guy was I mean so you can imagine
trying to sue him or Brinkley that's a
game well our man is dirty it's just
like it's just like the DNC and though
it's just like all these people thing's
a piece of [ __ ] I need to take a
hardcore piss all this horse [ __ ] and
then let's come back new car yeah myself
a little candy bar in the meantime it's
the dark arts just all my drugs Dom my
drugs all fair we're back on opiate ever
gone so alive we don't live current
events yeah you got you are the first
one we talked about this on Monday
Jada Smith I didn't I can't believe it
so it's it did I said to you
now we talked about this didn't we they
laid five million huh we talked about
him The Smiths giving Tyreese five
million dollars turns out that was not
true Will Smith and then we're like they
came out like we never and then you post
video how do you know are you up to date
on Clarice from the drama no I just know
he been upset about because The Fast and
the Furious they don't get along without
custody but he's crazy so then he goes
my brother from another mother blah blah
blah
Will Smith is wiring five million
dollars to me so you pay my legal fees
we're always brothers and then Will
Smith came out was like yo where we
never talked to him
we're not give him [ __ ] we don't know
him like that a source very close to
Will Smith said that they never gave it
to him
and but they did say that they're very
worried about Tyrese is uh many hey
there yeah that's Allen Iverson esque
right there
he looks like Flavor Flav right there
he's not doing well no he's going crazy
no this is really no and that's thick
smoke that ain't our American spirits
you know that you know Native American
ain't that juju
fix her he's happening he's having a
real breakdown that's true in line about
five million he was like still waiting
for that wire chancellor he comes he's
posting videos non-stop away still
waiting he's I'm still waiting for that
wire chance come through but I gotta go
do this show flying private in my
[ __ ] fur coat and really he's going
crazy
he had like child abuse accusations from
his ex-wife but those charges were
dropped now those were dropped which who
knows maybe like were the [ __ ] would I
care yeah that's so much money that's a
lot of money boy but you wouldn't give
to your doing white area kids adult
white don't wait yeah no I would give
we're gonna lose his other roles now
what's the most that somebody's asked
you to borrow in that you lent them you
know what to name their name but that
you honestly did the most I asked to
borrow or that you've asked to borrow or
someone has asked you to borrow for me I
think it's just about maybe 400 bucks I
think dollars right Brian you've been in
more issues if you're an adult
I've led some
I let in front of mine $16,000 do you
ever pay back no no I didn't expect it
to I gave it to him I said this is this
is this is not money I'm gonna see you
back but I didn't do it because he just
really needed it yeah and I have no
regrets about it I was gonna buy this
house that was just at the time I barely
out of my price range
maybe he'd help with the down payment
and my friend at the time like I'll just
do it and then you just pay me back
we'll have a monthly plan and then so
once it came down to it I didn't pull
the trigger I'm like no if I can't get
the house myself it's gonna cheap in
this I didn't do it when he was down Wow
super surprised and it's cool yeah super
cool borrowing money that's uh that's
weird man yeah rather just give it away
later just yeah
if you get it back to me you can get it
back to me but yeah that cuz I mean you
have your own the house I know what that
is like it's a real friend like if it's
a real friend and they really need it or
something that is up and you can do it
like you know it's you you just have to
have that choice a lot of times you're
enabling them though right we're their
fuck-ups and then they're like oh can I
get 10 G's I'll pay it back yeah and you
know you're just extending the time of
being a [ __ ] right yeah right because
other people if they need money they
have means of hard work in other ways to
go about getting it sure where it's
gonna be substantial works like if you
if you if you had you wanted to start a
business say I'd be like and you I don't
want to borrow me about hey I bet I
would lend it to you because I would go
yeah the chance of you paying me back
are very high also you know you see him
all the time in here and then braid up
now I shake him down a fire and you
could have the audience get angry at him
you have you have well why does me 16
grand from Beth from mixed martial arts
fights but that's how do you suppose get
a tat a little more than 16 right what
about that little I'm gonna get a tattoo
Laurie what about shoulders
macgillicuddy that little guy that
fought and beat what's-his-name with the
tattoos all over him TJ yeah man that
dude is the angst I'm super Jason what
else you got you hear this one so a
tourist so a girl brought pain pills
tramadol have you guys ever heard of
tramadol a trite rhyme at all
like back in the day yeah yeah there's
nothing to him they're not great they're
not kind of the weak [ __ ] painkiller
get that Sheila my solution for taking
procedures yeah so she brought so
apparently she's married to this guy
that lives in Egypt she visits him like
three or four times a year oh she's a
toilet girl I don't know yeah yeah but
uh so she brought 25 tabs of tramadol
and apparently it's illegal there but
not only is it illegal she's facing up
to 25 years and even the death penalty
for bringing it there she had no idea
she says oh well light her up dude
sometimes you gotta go Jesus Christ what
I say do you consider reading all this
it says hers light her life is in danger
she can't stay in there any longer she
will be murdered Egyptian jails are
probably not the 15 by 15 that it's 15
by 15 she's in there 25 other women with
a hole in the floor for a toilet yeah
well I say keep her in two days for each
pill and then just let her out but she's
got to walk back or whatever to get to
where she needs to go oh wow I think
it's fair
there was a 40 game of Thrones style she
knows the rules fourteen-year-old in
Saudi Arabia had a joint and and she got
30 years in jail and we were all told as
kids we were like you guys have any
drugs on you and the American Embassy
can't do anything to help Wow the
government will put you in jail I was 13
and this fourteen-year-old kid in
Dhahran she was a girl she was sense to
30 years in jail having a joint that's
and my friend pick you up my friend
Kevin made me smoked I stick and I
remember being forced to smoked I stick
on if somebody calls right now I'd go to
jail forever
yeah and sure Saudi Arabia they don't
[ __ ] around but how stupid is this so it
said if she could have made about $30 if
she sold it was black market well now
stupid yeah this looks like Egypt do bad
yeah this looks like a dude she'll be
okay but this this seems to be the this
this feels like it's a hard case where
she got caught up in a bureaucracy right
and they're gonna look at the evidence
and they'll get her ass she probably
didn't even know that it was in her
purse I'm guessing you think I think she
knew but it it's such a
oh you don't think they're gonna lose
right he probably some paid some
[ __ ] who cares but who knows it's an
attitude some people these you know if
she's a you know some people cop an
attitude and who knows we don't have all
the facts but you know the British have
done a lot of harm in the world and
sometimes you got to take one down look
I read this whole article and it's a
piece of [ __ ] and I wasted my time upset
I'm upset that the lady wasted my time
making me read this [ __ ] that makes
sense now she's affected your life yeah
not just Egypt yeah I should get five
bucks revving to read this [ __ ] you know
it's not a good news day let's look at
this a father the t-pain no a father
killed his son long cuz he was gay
that's pretty much the only reason
that's what his ex his ex-wife said oh
that guy that kids going harder hair
paint with his lover in that 14-year old
dude he's 14 and just out good for him
that's heartbreaking man that is they're
all wait the kid was killed by yes the
kids are how highway patrolman as well
in California
yeah buddy man I can't imagine he hated
the fact that some is gay
the team's former foster mom said I'm
sure that the inside of his mind he
would rather have a dead son indication
so then the dad didn't say that this is
the teens foster mom saying that yeah
let's kind of messed up that they use
that as a clickbait the hall there's a
bunch going on here cuz the police said
how old is he 14 14 the police said the
teen lived on own at an apartment where
he's fatally shot so he had a foster
mother foster parents the dads this
[ __ ] who hated that son was gay there's
all just sounds like comes from a
horrible sounds like he's got the
dumbest dad on them and how old's that
boyfriend that boyfriend looks like he
might be in as a young 20s let's get a
peek at that gentleman huh yeah the
boyfriend so who knows he might be
dyeing his roots out who knows what's
going on here but it is very sad and
also the father looks dehydrated God
does he ever yeah we need some
electrolyte you need electrolytes
coconut water
something wrong with him some sort of
Pedialyte do
I'm sure you don't have it as a current
event chin but are you you're not a big
sports families this guy you'll
appreciate this behind this guy his name
was Gordon he was a they all-pro
receiver had I think three games over
200 receiving yards he's one of the best
receivers especially in the league but
he kept getting busted for marijuana
over and over finally got suspended
he missed the whole season they missed
another season then they suspend him
indefinitely for he's kept failing
marijuana hmm finally they reinstated
him just I think last weekend yeah
practice with the brown stuff like that
he did an interview on g GQ i tweeted it
out they said how bad was it
he said before every game for every
practice i was drunk and high wow you're
talking freak Wow like set some crazy
right like three games over 200 yards
receiving I get stuff straight up be
just an addict a straight up addict he
said though the way I deal with things
I've just shots I take shots for
practice and they said how would you do
it before a game cuz you have to stay at
the the players hotel here's well they
let you go home if you have to go get
stuff so I just go oh I got to go home
and I have my routine my shots smoke go
to the game ball out I can't even go I
can't I'm afraid to meet the pizza guy
downstairs if I'm stone me too like how
smoke paranoid but I don't think black
guys get paranoid dude you don't think
they responded with the SEC no I've
never even met a black guy who said I'm
nervous yeah I haven't either
yeah hundreds of my friends not one is
ever been like dude you know what
feeling pretty nervous about this that's
a great point
yeah Iverson there's murderers and it's
like magic you know it's like I've been
Josh Gordon chin that's tripe in Josh
Gordon get to nervous hey Jimmy break
hey Jim is there like to bring up
another parent killing his child for us
between events Jesus Wow damn
Gordon sober Wow sober now dude are you
talking super baller - Wow like that I
mean all-pro if you were a nervous black
person I'd love to have them call him to
the show
how's it been fam not long yeah just
cause the GQ interview
release all that stuff thank you and the
good thing is all the s to do is catch a
couple balls and on Cleveland he will be
good dude the team is oh and nine are
they were Owen eight yeah who's the
worst they haven't won there you go it
looks goodness yeah but if some it's
crazy man so look so Gordon has been
slapped with multiple suspensions
repeated violent in the leaked substance
abuse policy two games John 13 10 games
two on 14 entire season 2 on 15 2016 he
was reinstated four-game suspension he
was on his way back playing and then
there's a warrant out for his rest
oh you know three strikes yeah so keep
going down um so they put him in 64 2 36
3 2 3 they put him in rehab but and it
saved his life because he talked about
just how crazy things were going so he's
crazy fast too he's doing a very fast
he's like a Prius
but in order sit down Jim first the
facts we talked about what he's doing oh
here you go
what point did you come first a my attic
know who's highly functional I probably
know 3 probably half a glass or a couple
shots to try and warm my system up
basically to get the motor running
that's what I would do for games check
out I so to give us an example we do
before games I used to make a ritual
before every game that already been drug
tested that week or that day before the
game I know not a couple of days to buy
clean my system even for I was getting
tested for alcohol I take the biggest
bong rip I could and try to conceal the
smell of it through my clothes and I'd
be dressed up to go to the game Wow a
bunch of guys would smoke weed before a
game Wow bro make these pre-made shots
grandmary a could drink it down smooth
whisky half a glass couple shots try to
warrant my system a crazy that that's
awesome dude that's awesome when you're
on a performance-enhancing drug how
impressive is that it is impressive I
mean look I think some people's systems
just react
better with it with drugs and alcohol
yeah but for him it was a way to deal
with the the nerves and like depression
he's not bringing like comes from a
rough upbringing you're right there's
guys like John Jones too can do coke
cannot train than just and it's their
way of dealing with the stress of being
a professional it might keep them looser
or something Awards just they want to do
coke and still want to fight and party
yeah or it helps them they just like the
party yeah like nobody's gonna like what
or the or he's twenty five with a
shitload of money and fame and likes to
party yeah which is all the time is that
that's what I would be doing everyone's
liked it they're professional athletes
they should do this wool who decides and
dictates what a professional athlete
should act like right yeah dude I was 25
and had no money and I was still doing
coke and going grocery shopping and [ __ ]
you know so it's like how many games
would you ask me that you got something
your system every game by every game in
my career including college definitely
called oh but see here's where it gets
weird not weird but it explains a lot I
didn't plan on living to 18 day-to-day
life what's gonna happen next so you
self-medicate with xanax marijuana
coating to help numb those nerve so you
just function every day yeah that's what
that's what that's how he got his own
way otherwise he might have imploded
killers I don't know what he's like as a
person like you think he's a you think
he's just I mean you see something does
it have you watch this last chance you
have you seen that show last chance you
on Netflix
no dude watch that series unbelievable
it's about it's about this college of
Mississippi it's a documentary where
they take like the war the they take to
notes
yes problem child's or people have had
an athletic issues that they're bigger
universities and a lot of d1
universities and they go to this
division it's a community college in
Mississippi and they play football and
it's some the best documenting I've ever
seen it was a pro Ryan take your ass the
episodes really yeah it's called last
chance you and it's on net I see it on
that stage you think it's stupid you
what I'm good so good as ever see that
movie see you know it's it's so
unbelievably good and blew my mind I
definite
and that Ric Flair 34 30s out now ro the
best 34 30 ad why just started watching
it last he suggests me to that like late
like a yeah yeah woo why so good whoa be
the man you gotta beat them it's just
the way he changed the gaming like he
was the first he's a first transgender
really that stayed male Wow he came out
there was jackets and beautiful he was
the first one that are like showboat
with girls money fame like he's the one
who did that so Floyd Connor all them
dying really from him and his his promos
his reads he would do like his his
promos he'd rip they go dude you come up
with new [ __ ] all time with girls and
money
how are you so creative he's like well
it's not being creative I do that the
night before like I lived a life like
yeah it was what I did but is he where
was he from originally what was his
nationality he was adopted and his
parents I don't know man I don't know
and I was talking about with chin on the
big ground breakdown where I'm yeah I
was I'm such a big fan of Ric Flair the
only thing that hurt was how shitty feel
father he was yeah he's the worst dad
well yeah he had all these kids and it's
interviews kids and they're just pissed
like he was never there he's not around
and Ric Flair's like I don't want to
tell you like to be Ric Flair he can't
be a dad yeah he was never didn't ever
there and they said he'd come home his
wife would go his ex-wife his first wife
said he'd come home and he'd be like
playing with the kids Mike this is so
[ __ ] boring and so what I want to do
and just leave yeah he would DDT the
kids and [ __ ] in those takeoffs bodies
baby just bring like Cabbage Patch Kids
and like my bat here's 10 oh yeah maybe
like do doesn't work that way he was
just tagging a stepdad just yeah so yeah
they see that he'd do so then they were
interviewing the kids there's just so
much anger like the kids like [ __ ] this
dude he's just the worst man if I was
but I mean that yeah what do you do you
got a sacrifice it you know I don't know
and he didn't have the big money in the
beginning that's when they you know like
if you have a kids know that that's to
me if you have kids that's your
responsibility I don't think yeah for
sure he couldn't have had him he never
should have had when you have him you
got human beings you have to take care
of but what do you if you do have them
and you're in your state you and you're
gonna create that type of stigma yeah
your Ric Flair yeah you
not you know you gonna take care it's a
double-edged sword because you couldn't
be Ric Flair and still do that I'll do
about Ric Flair for a dad oh dude I
remember my watching my buddy body slam
his dad one time in the yard and pretend
he was Ric Flair's one of the most
beautiful things I've ever seen
I gotta be and if that doesn't happen
I'll if he doesn't do that I'll never
you don't see that I never like you know
at UFC events the whole no matter where
you at the crowd goes whoa whoa and
there's all this chance I'm like what
his people's deal with Ric Flair I hate
ya I'm I think I'm too old for Ric right
I was too young for to be a big Ric
Flair fan right I got into it he watched
a documentary like holy [ __ ]
well he was the greatest danger we come
out yeah all the lights and it just
reflecting off the sequins on his gun
and like you didn't even know what was
going on you know you don't know if it
was a senior citizen or who it was
walking out bring-bring
how was that great of a wrestler that
was a thing he was just a amazing
showman he wasn't a bad wrestler but he
wasn't that built Ford he's only [ __ ] he
wasn't really really big gonna rest guy
yeah he's dressing family was coming out
when Ric Flair was when I was young
huge I was I was a macho man warrior in
Rico
Razor Ramon oh yeah those guys I mean
that was all now that was my generation
I was WWF yeah yeah he's WCW handsome
guy yeah and he was out there in that
NWA he said the docks they slept with
over 10,000 I'm here Wow best of Ric
Flair watches the world use the first
light talk like this like bragging here
beautiful and any woman in the world I
want just like that yeah yeah dude this
was this way you can see where Conor
McGregor and all these guys get it right
there's no what it is that's mcgregors5
these products you're talking about all
man ripslinger
clothes on them stealing yeah he was on
a test 100s little bottle he though
why not did I be drinking it a
hemorrhoid or two he's just freaking out
it was crazy though you know see the 34
3 I'm not I'm yeah that being in
wrestling as a grown-ass man now but
that was the best 34 he was a game
changer huh the only disappoint part is
doing his kids are interviewed and you
see how shitty the person he was I
haven't watched all of that yet i'ma
watch whatever end of it so now sort of
watch it I can see the end I didn't
watch the end
salt they mainly begin in the middle but
it'll bummed me out about the dad
well yeah Ric Flair was one of a kind
man he was he was one you impersonated
you know I mean I wonder how many kids
are on wheelchairs because they jumped
off the roof you know dressed in on
those flips and a bad cake trying to be
Ric Flair yeah now where's that
documentary where's that [ __ ]
documental fucked-up depressing document
wrestling with wrestling with my
disabilities that's what it should be
called what else you got to it produce
it okay some guy that's rolling it like
this camera stealing drivers tips oh
yeah these will do some ladies what do
you mean they're actually pretty hot and
I'm a FEMINIST did it is it a feminist
yeah I mean look at the lady he's about
to drop him off and then you can see
this girl looking she looks like Kendall
Duke right at the calendar look right -
yeah she's Jax's tip and bounces that's
did they catch her no that was in New
York but they said the [ __ ] they
deleted her access to the app yeah Wow
for fruit release in uber but also
alright you delete I'm in New York and
take yellows by the way good luck her
getting a job now when yeah then look
that up that's on the internet she's a
piece of [ __ ] well it's just a shadow
person
yeah it just greedy that's what it is
greedy dude I remember one time I stole
something but I think it was just like a
beavis and butthead necklace from a shop
yeah it be whatever beautiful I'm just
kind of lonely
alright so apparently they think it's a
ghost well they said it could be a prank
but this the school has no idea how it
was done no idea how it's done so
this is leaving ghosts well I do believe
in ghost Orleans you gotta know bro
friends were [ __ ] spirits growing up
yeah that's a so there's an Ireland
Dublin oh definitely they got goes let
me see the actual minute marks here I'll
fast forward it take a look at that
alright door Oh door shuts okay
somebody's at what time I don't know 307
and these are motion detected cameras oh
okay they turn on when they see motion
okay confirmed and then let's see right
now so lockers just moving on its own
and the day nice carry me fast for it to
hear that's that would scare the [ __ ]
out of me if I was and there's more
stuff coming so papers flying out of a
locker how these kids do this oh they
could do this to their children and
they're bored its Ireland haven't done
anything in hundreds of years and then
check this is the last thing that
happens the last thing they had was up
there how would they do that last thing
that happens in the seas was a big
disease they had their plague with a
rope yeah well so all the associated
ropes on everything ropes on ropes on
ropes no just kids with ropes let's try
it again let me see that [ __ ] yeah let's
see a little bit of that dirty magic
again that [ __ ] again you'll see
anything do you see a rope on that so
there's a door here
well the door thing is easy cuz it's
just somebody opens the door you know
but no one's there is there for to close
shut the Rope would have to be on the
other end I usually have rope on each
ends there's no ropes
I mean if it's computer-generated oh
they have rope in our Ireland dude and
that's somebody pushing a locker dude
we're all [ __ ] us out of a locker
yeah because you can see there's a yeah
there's a window there so people yeah
okay and that looks like it's empty now
let's go look at this partner how did
this open up
and then papers flow papers flop first
look like right what kind of can you go
back and look at that that was
interesting
Sam oh yeah same time so but then help
this this wet floor this is cool and
let's see how it moves what part of it
moves first Jen let's go watch here it
is mmm look so you just pulled up from
the side yeah
slow it down brother or it's YouTube
well yeah you can do something Wow damn
powerful MJ's education channel gotta be
fishing thanks MJ oh it's nice of them
to say thank you too holy [ __ ] it's low
no yes it's cool though alright just
give it about half an hour dude look at
that here we go right here look it's
necessary though you got to believe in
the dark magic
it does seem more scary another we're
waiting for it cuz that was cool that
sound there uh-huh like we know like we
won't have any [ __ ] idea like very
dorks we're gonna figure it out there
was some sort of ghost hunters [ __ ] both
of you this is you know I like the glady
who's caught in Egypt better she wasted
my time less than this [ __ ] god
damnit they busted a man trying to be a
ghost dude they caught a man yeah really
what was he doing grabbing girls no
trying to keep up Motel Hornet and
trying to be make it haunted to be gonna
I believe you your charges pressed if
you do that type of [ __ ] I mean they
caught him driving a Dodge Ram and he is
wearing a ghost an outfit yeah that's
creepy I mean it's a crime is that it
chamber you get more dying kids there's
another one what is it someone died just
kidding this is a DMV employee that
dressed up as a sloth that's also from
the movie Zootopia which is oh that's so
hard in that so yes all that beautiful a
DMV yeah and he probably killed himself
after
damn oh yeah I think it dark deal well
you brought it up dark do the ladies
about to get killed in a prison I didn't
know about her till I got here I have to
think about her tonight this part
Solaris I love this you call
have you seen Zootopia three humped
camel pregnant so he just told him a
joke
what shall I taste one respond leave his
face what flash Rangers would like head
that stuff on the side frightening it
was so awesome man that it - that's it
it's funny now how long have you guys
known chan is what I want to know here
uh when we left Fox Sports we hired two
that's beautiful so how long we been
here - how long we've been together
alright exactly here this month Oh
November or November right yeah we
started November game it's been a year I
know it sounds crazy I wanted to give a
little Congrats drop the knowledge that
I had I heard two really cool Japanese
concepts that my friend hunter mots
explained on mixed mental arts my other
podcast
what's mother well do you know for ten
points do you know the two Japanese
concepts of iki guy and kutsuki kosugi
yeah kutsuki is you know what I like to
do make a sound and see if it's an Asian
circuit do it in China tell you all
right you know
who down you said got here country what
about this one dude do you I'm not a kid
that sounds Vietnamese boom Rock one
time I said truck one time somebody said
oh oh do try one it's a little here like
Tao I ordered something it's hey you
know what a little race but it's fun if
you are on yeah some of those languages
are like the Vietnamese is a strong
language you're good at it they'll give
some experience in life you copy this
[ __ ] oh boy
wait what he flip guys like that modern
dual deep I feel like it's a struggle
for you I don't like you're dying it's
in me bro
well the reason is like when you say
denise has her Haro is because there's a
great deal of that in Japanese they are
all right zopi we should go Bush knows
how like because it Karen you're not
dead serious brides that really tries to
be Japanese Hilux you know you know that
means how much you know yeah
it means hurry up oh is that true - yes
eyebrows very different languages
Brendan chop I know but I better
the airports and I'll ask what they're
speaking he knows yeah that's cool I'd
always pretend I know and I just give
wrong information that's a good game I
talked to this um Stone Smith mm-hmm
this guy was a Marine who was like how
do I do it okay I know somebody saw the
job I said I get a podcast or the listen
he's a stone Smith where he does like he
said what can I do your podcast oh yeah
it sounds like whatever get fourteen
listeners no listen it was fascinating
because the guy [ __ ] he was this
marine he's built like a brick [ __ ]
yeah the guy the guy the guy goes I
didn't know it was a job he was it was
soldier for a long time comes out and he
goes this economy what am I gonna do he
he learns this it goes and takes this by
accident sees these guys talking about
stone cutting and he learns the ancient
art of of [ __ ] stone smithing which
means like these guys can build walls
and he like fire pits and even houses
laying stone on stone and it and without
any mortar hmm so they can create
archways it's an ancient technique right
so back in the day they didn't use
mortar so you got to cut that [ __ ]
stone just perfectly and put it together
and the last 300 [ __ ] years those
walls like that [ __ ] lasts forever
so why would you learn that ancient art
well guess what rich people pay off [ __ ]
my neighbor's driveway like that or a
fire pit or a stairway or a house whoa
that am it cuz it's you know you did and
when you deal with a guy that he's like
I crave beauty he's built [ __ ] like
just like huge all he does is he goes
seventy percent of his of the men who
come to work for him don't make the cut
it's just he'll go I'll come into a
drive whether you're bored it's just too
hard
look how could it's so precise you come
in the driveway check this out
500 tons 500 tons of rock and it calls
it raw rock now it's not stone till the
man dressed it down until it dresses it
properly so you got granted 500 tons of
[ __ ] granite and then he goes I'm
gonna take this and I'm gonna turn that
into something beautiful Wow and you got
a dress it every single stone and they
have all these rituals and some and he
was talking about his [ __ ] him like he's
a real samurai he's like this huge guy
and I got these two awesome concepts
from he goes well III
live I let the art of Iike guy and I was
like what is it you cut he you guys
something that and he goes well it's the
Japanese thing of my life and I believe
everybody should live this way mmm
it goes like this am I good at it do I
enjoy it look I'm good at it I enjoy it
the world needs it and I get paid for it
because and that is when you when you
satisfy all of those four things you
will you will master something good at
it I enjoy it the world needs it I'm
good at it I enjoy it the world needs it
and I get paid for it that's what that
should be he said that should be all
your young men young people in this
world that should be your guiding
principle then he talked about kutsuki
which is the idea of the ancient look so
the Japanese they'll take a pot and
they'll break it like that like a vase
and the idea is you put it together you
fill the cracks in with gold and that's
a metaphor for your life because we all
come broken as people and you're talking
about therapy and all this why I was
thinking about this and then it's up to
you to fill all your [ __ ] broken
cracks with gold that's that is the
Japanese notion of how you become a work
of art how your life and you as a person
become a work of art Katsuki cut circuit
so out of gold boy you're supposed to be
broken as you get older fill those
[ __ ] cracks with a little gold I like
that too Japanese concepts I want to
share them Suki to you and I want to
swear to God I hope you find your gold I
kind of want to build I kind of want to
build it out of stone I really do you
know what I could see you getting into
some type of masonry or outdoor or
training of some type of ass piece I
need it shoes so honest like you either
if you think about it think about
working with rock where you can't use
mortar good man I would rather do build
rocks I don't know it's it's oh it's a
work of art because you have to be
honest if you don't do it perfectly
precise it doesn't work it's so much
other [ __ ] I'd rather I don't know dude
it's an art form you should take that up
crazy so much time now I bet you'd
finish projects on time too yeah you
should be so good at that you'd be
really responsible what do you guys
think up rock shaping you don't know my
dream don't [ __ ] piss on my dream
Rock
it's not Rock shaping its Rock dressing
mother [ __ ] what it is okay I guess I'm
dealing with a room full of ignorance
right now it's just you trying to just
not face the fact that you got here late
deal I'm just trying to pop my brother
yeah I got about this yeah man it comes
out every Monday it's been great and um
and then I'm just gonna be in Huntsville
Alabama next week at the stand up alive
with us yeah I'll be in Calgary at a
place called Cowboys just one night and
I think that's November first but Mike
or December for some mike young my name
my boy your boy and I'm Santino and PG
avene so pretty excited about the other
line oh yeah so just one night in
Calgary at its place called Cowboys but
otherwise I'll be in Huntsville Alabama
November 16th through the 19th and you
can check out my podcast this past
weekend nice and you know I appreciate
you guys having me so you're my hero
much always so you make me laugh harder
than anyone thanks man
I like being around you guys and I just
appreciate getting to work with you the
other night and to see at the club this
week you're a work of kosugi dudes all
your crack so good luck finding gold
thanks dude and good luck with your rock
building I appreciate that
it's not Rock building that's Rock
dressing I'm not going to shaping your
own it's not rock it's stone tell your
therapist about shaping it's not a not
shape my rocks as much because and given
become habitual and you can have a bad
habit of jerking off at night okay but
legit like before it touch it touches
can be done where you gonna be man I'm
gonna be at New York City November 17th
and 18th at Gotham comedy club if the
fires permit oh if the fires prevent and
then we got now if you pick up Rock
building you don't have time for
comedies it's not I'm gonna die again
the end the day leave me Rob its
passenger you don't say tell you just
does it with raw say that and then drops
gel metaphors know if you go Hawks he's
a stone Smith you bill rocks you are
ignorant it's a stone smitten bill
Raheem a Bills beautiful things yeah I
did too when I was 12 and don't ask me
about rammed earth housing yeah I want I
can keep thinking about your dates I
mean I'm in wiseguys Thanksgiving
weekend and then
I am at Cobbs comedy club December 7th
8th and 9th come see me uh let's see
this coming out Thursday morn tonight
I'm in Charlotte
are you really Charlotte Friday and
Saturday I am at Zanies in Nashville
Sunday I'm in Columbus come see me tea
fat cake calm
most of those shows are sold out but
we're releasing my comp tickets so it's
Charlotte tonight Friday Saturday
Nashville Sunday Columbus get them tea
fat K calm this is the finally kid we're
out